[MUSIC PLAYING]
Antimatter.
That word probably makes you
think of Star Trek or Doctor
Who, or something
else like that.
But far from being
science fiction,
antimatter is science fact.
And it's one of the
most interesting
substances in the Universe.
In fact, its behaviour is one of
the biggest mysteries that
we have in fundamental
physics today.
And I work on an experiment at
CERN's Large Hadron Collider,
which is devoted to trying to
understand this illusive stuff
in more detail.
So why is it so important?
Well, the deal is that we
understand that everything in
the Universe is made of
fundamental particles--
matter--
and we know that every type of
fundamental particle has an
antimatter counterpart that
behaves as a mirror image,
oppositely-charged version.
The interesting thing about
antimatter is it when it meets
normal matter, it annihilates,
releasing
enormous amounts of energy.
So if I have a quarter of a
gramme of antimatter meeting a
quarter of a gramme of normal
matter, the resulting
annihilation has the explosive
force of 5 kilotons of TNT.
Now, that's something you'd
notice, but it doesn't seem to
be happening around us on Earth
and it doesn't seem to
be happening out in space,
anywhere, where we've been
able to look.
And that is the mystery.
That's really strange, because,
we think, that when
the Universe started in the Big
Bang, half of it was made
of antimatter.
And just after the Big Bang, the
fundamental particles that
composed the Universe met, and
the antimatter and matter
versions annihilated each other,
and these annihilations
created photons of light, that
then could split into new
pairs of matter and antimatter
particles.
And this whole process of
annihilation continued, as the
Universe expanded
and cooled down.
Until, eventually, a few seconds
after the Big Bang,
the Universe had cooled so much
as it had expanded that
there was no longer enough
energy left in these
annihilation from the
antimatter-matter collisions
to make new pairs of matter and
antimatter, and the whole
process of annihilation
stopped at that time.
Of what remains in the Universe
now, what built stars
and galaxies, and us is a
consequence of a very tiny
difference between the amount of
matter and antimatter that
must have existed
at that point.
But the fact that there was
that difference is so
significant, because it tipped
the Universe in favour of
matter and let us exist today.
And it's for that reason that
we really need to understand
antimatter.
It's still one of the biggest
unsolved mysteries in
fundamental physics.
And that's why our experiments
are eagerly taken data to try
and find the difference
from LHC collisions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We have no underlying
explanation for why antimatter
should be different.
We almost had no expectation
that antimatter should exist.
And only that equation that
predicted it, well, that's our
only theoretical input.
And that predicts matter and
antimatter should be the same.
[MUSIC PLAYING]